[Music]
stanford university
today's class is on responsible limits
on data and technology data privacy
ethics and new governance frameworks we
have over here three speakers who span
various industries rob from the academia
perspective as a political theorist matt
from government in the pentagon in dc
and jeff with his experience on the
industry side i'll kick off by
introducing our three panelists and also
have just a few initial topics to cover
around biases and algorithms privacy
surveillance ethical frameworks and the
role of industry versus government so
i'll start by introducing rob he's a
professor of political science at
stanford he's also director of the
center for ethics in society as well as
co-director of the center on
philanthropy and civil society
at stanford his work focuses on applied
ethics in addition to education
inequality through all of philanthropy
in the public sector and other topics on
democratic theory
rob hopefully i capture that it's so
hard to capture everything you're doing
well you missed the big one that's
relevant which is i'm also now i'm
directing too many things the associate
director of the institute for
human-centered ai
that is true that is another role that
rob has recently taken on as one of his
additional stanford center directing
roles and also has launched the very
popular ethics curriculum at stanford
targeted our computer scientists we also
have matt williams he's
been in defense and intelligence
community on the us government side for
about 25 years he's currently on the
staff of the chief of naval operations
for the u.s navy focused on information
warfare he previously served as a
special assistant to the director of
naval intelligence and in various
leadership positions for the office of
naval intelligence and the dia the
defense intelligence agency matt
hopefully i captured everything you did
i know some of it's top secret though so
we'll eliminate those parts from your
bio and last but not least we have jeff
wong who's global chief innovation
officer at ernst young he leads a team
whose mission is to research and explore
new technologies his experience spans
various parts of industry prior to
joining ey that includes work at bcg the
venture capital firm jafco ventures
jpmorgan ebay and also is affiliated
with oxford sitting on their advisory
board for their entrepreneurship
initiatives as well as for a non-profit
organization that's focused on
increasing diversity and inclusion in ai
so thank you all for joining us today
i'll kick off with one hot topic that's
often discussed is discrimination and
bias in algorithms and why should we
care about discrimination and biases in
algorithms maybe we'll start with matt
since i think based on some
conversations we've had
the perspective on how you think about
this from a military operations and
government standpoint is fairly
different than what we often see in all
that industry plays
yeah sure absolutely thanks ernestine
we
so so frankly discrimination you know
and and and by season in algorithms is
important to military operations but as
ernestine alluded to it's for slightly
different reason when we are conducting
operations against adversaries whether
they be kinetic or otherwise we want the
right answer so we don't want to go
after the wrong target or to take the
wrong steps or or frankly um think we're
understanding the intelligence in a
different way than is actually uh the
truth and so many times there any time
there are errors in that process whether
that's cognitive biases in a human's
mind or related biases in the algorithms
that's going to cause a problem for us
and what we're especially worried about
is people intentionally corrupting those
data sets or those algorithms and we are
we do know that there are people out
there and actually it's it happens all
over the regular internet where students
actually go and manipulate
manipulate the algorithm to get
different results i think what 10 years
ago it was called a google bomb right to
intentionally corrupt the algorithm of
the google search engine for for
whatever reason same thing happens to us
and we're worried about same thing can
happen to us and we're worried about
adversaries either getting into our data
sets or getting into our algorithms or
figuring out how to manipulate them from
the outside so either presenting us with
false data or misleading data that
ultimately uh directs our the end
results of our algorithms in the wrong
direction and a question for rob and
jeff what should we be doing to
eliminate these sorts of biases
yeah so ernest if i might jump in on
this question
first i have to say i'm a little bit
jealous that rob gets to wear like 52
different stanford hats and that matt
has in his tagline some of it is top
secret so i need to be doing better
better more interesting things in the
world apparently now i'll actually see
if you don't mind i want to address that
first question first which is why is it
important so i'll take a little i'll
take an industry view on this and and i
actually go back to thinking about
redlining from the 1930s i think most
people know it is but redlining was when
they literally drew maps and on maps
they drew a red line and they marked
certain communities as hazardous or high
risk
and that went from the 1930s to i think
the late 1960s i may be getting my dates
wrong and i think somebody on this call
probably is a better expert than i am
but that obviously led to who got credit
to buy homes start businesses et cetera
build equity and obviously not obviously
but it was highly related to where the
minorities were living at the time so in
the 1930s 60 years after that so after
the 1960s when it was repealed 60 years
after that we're still seeing the impact
and effects of it i saw one stat where
three out of four of the communities
that were redline are still basically in
poverty so the echo of that sonic boom
of that redlining effort still echoes
today despite it being 60 years later so
when i look at the context of why is it
important to think about bias and
discrimination and make sure that in
algorithms we don't have it today is
because the implications of us getting
it wrong i would hate to think that
we're sitting here in this era and then
60 years from now we did something we
should have made a better more distinct
effort to make sure we took out that
bias now so that 60 years from now oh
yeah the algorithm was doing something
but we didn't recognize it and i think
we've seen many high-profile failures
out there where
credit was it was given to one gender
but not the other the same household but
one gender but not the other there's no
reason for that where we see distinct
ethnic ethnicities bias in terms of
algorithms around talent talent who
should be hired who should be
interviewed questions so we've seen some
major failures around that so i think
that when we are very public failures
around so when i think about it i think
about that responsibility as well which
is our responsibility to make sure that
this doesn't echo through the the
generations because we didn't do
something here
i'll pause there because i've spoken
long enough and i think rob maybe you
can answer that one and and ernestine's
real question to us
so ernestine the question is
what can we do to mitigate or eliminate
algorithmic bias discrimination and i'm
sure you have lots of thoughts given the
work that hai's been doing to right on
the high center has been doing around
that
yeah okay i'll say the first thing which
i hope is obvious but
oftentimes doesn't seem to be obvious
but
the topic of algorithmic fairness or
algorithmic bias is something that we
need to invest time to study and to
identify where the problems are
because we want a world in which
algorithmic models don't amplify the
already considerable array of human bias
and human discrimination for the same
reasons that jeff just described
algorithmic models have a veneer of
scientific authority or mathematical
objectivity and therefore can amplify
biases that are baked in whether it's
through the training set the design of
the model the particular ways it's
deployed with a human in the loop or not
in the loop
so basically if you care about fairness
in the world you should also care about
algorithms because that's where a lot of
decision making is now being made
what can we do about algorithmic bias
and discrimination
the the first thing to understand is
that there are many different places
where bias and discrimination can creep
into an algorithm from the
choice of the training data from the
design of the algorithmic model to
various deployment circumstances and i'm
just mentioning several of the sort of
places in which bias and discrimination
can creep in
and
i'll end just this sort of overview by
saying something perhaps to a cs or
computer science or engineer crowd might
seem as a radical idea but which to a
philosopher seems rather ordinary
which is that the
the very work of being an engineer of
creating an algorithmic model as a
programmer requires that the problem
you're trying to solve be
computationally tractable you can't make
an algorithmic model that has a
predictive accuracy without
mathematically operationalizing the
various things that you want the model
to represent
which is to say you need to try to find
various ways to
make
computationally representable what
fairness or
anti-discrimination happens to be
and in the real world the world of human
beings fairness is not something easily
reduced to a mathematical theorem or
property or equation which is to say
fairness can differ in different social
circumstances
and when that's the case you get what we
now think is familiar in computer
science you get a set of impossibility
results if you choose fairness
specification a in some circumstances
and you also think in other
circumstances it's better to choose
fairness circumstance b
you can't plug them both equally into an
algorithmic model where they work
equally well in any situation you have
to make some fundamental choices
and those fundamental choices mean that
in different circumstances the models
will perform with bias and then
sometimes without bias in other words we
can't reduce justice to a math equation
philosophers and the rest of society
deserve a seat at the table when putting
algorithms together and deciding where
they're deployed so ashley in our class
has i love it when we actually present
the question in the other way so she
asks are there any cases that
algorithmic biases are beneficial
beneficial to whom or to what
that's a good rhetorical question i
don't know if ashley has additional
thoughts on that or
i just thought in general like
maybe some like medical cases or like
some studies maybe algorithmic biases
might increase the
the accuracy of like the outcome
yeah
sure i'll take a crack at that i think
if at the end of this class i try to
leave everyone with it with a single
message if i have had to distill what i
most hope to communicate today
it's that
whether we're engineers or
product managers or ceos or venture
capitalists or public policy makers
our work involves confronting value
trade-offs trade-offs where there's no
singularly correct answer no single
optimum
to reach we have to balance the
various different things that we care
about in the world like privacy versus
security which i know is another topic
on our minds for today
if you think that
life involves our professional lives
involved technology involves confronting
value trade-offs
then there are times where
we're trying to figure out whether an
algorithmic model with whatever bias it
has
is nevertheless an improvement over
the relatively abysmal performance of
humans in making decisions maybe we
count the algorithmic model as a
incremental improvement over the
relatively embarrassing performance of
humans alternatively let me give you a
particular example ashley jeff mentioned
the the lending models of credit scoring
and that type of stuff another place
where we find algorithmic model
algorithmic models used all the time
probably you've all been yourself
subjected to them are are hiring
decisions whenever you have huge
applicant pools lots of companies now
say ai screening models for
resumes
sometimes companies will say
can you provide us with an algorithmic
hiring tool that gives a bigger pool of
minorities or women because we're trying
to overcome
our human tendency in this company in
this sector to hire a bunch of white
dudes
and the answer is that comes at a
certain cost you're plugging as it were
a certain type of bias into the model to
overcome the history of human bias
and then you have all kinds of legal
questions to confront about whether or
not different types of waiting attached
to people on the basis of sex or on race
is even legally permissible
this just introduces the fact that
fairness is a social thing not a
mathematical thing and we have to make
choices and those choices
shouldn't be in the hands of engineers
alone
now rob i'm going to jump in on because
i think
you spoke so well on this so i just want
to emphasize i think that to your point
there's a matter of perspective on this
right so the bias works for those who
are advantaged by it and we i think in
the sensibility of this class and a
sensibility i think we all agree and i
agree with we're saying oh yes let's
bias it towards the underrepresented
classes so that we can tune an engine
that overcomes i think that's a a
perfect example of how we can tune
something and say now okay the bias the
the tuning it in is working for us in
the overall system
but there is obviously a matter of
perspective right for those who did get
credit or do get loans it's working well
for them
loans and credit is more available for
them so i think there is a matter of
perspective it's interesting because as
we get further into the some of the
questions that were posed prior to the
prior to starting sorry i think getting
into discussions about ethics and whose
perspective of ethics are we talking
about or whose perspective of bias are
we talking about because i think that
becomes
an important um factor when we think
about frameworks and how we want to how
you might want to think about it
that's a great point jeff and rob and i
think both of your discussions
clearly highlight the distinction that i
was trying to lead off with i don't
think it was particularly eloquent if
we're talking about bias as being a
challenge to the fairness of how we
treat others that's not what we care
about generally when it comes to formal
you know operations against foreign
adversaries we care about the same
technical things that occur in the bias
in a data set that does not represent uh
reality or as close to reality as we
could or an algorithm that was somehow
programmed in a way that corrupts the
sense of recreating reality and so
that's a huge distinction that i often i
i frankly find
comes down to our choice of words
bias is the right word for both sides of
that uh discussion but our language i
don't think has as the same number of
nuances
that it could in some of these
same number of definitions or words to
really make those distinctions as i go
forward that's mo what i just described
is mainly what i'm what i'm referring to
a lot of these things not to say the us
government doesn't have interests in
protecting
fairness for our own citizens but that's
not the general dod
focus
all good points for the sake of time
want to cover the next topic of privacy
and surveillance specifically given that
we're in the middle of a pandemic the
topic of vaccine passports which perhaps
has become a little politicized as well
in terms of some republican governors
signing executive orders limiting or
prohibiting the use of vaccine passports
and critics saying that they have
privacy concerns around that
in general how should we think about
balancing an individual's right to
control their personal information
versus the public benefits of containing
a virus
so i'll jump in
first on this one or see if the other
panels don't mind so
i i found this and and this sort of
builds off of what i was describing
before whose sense of privacy and whose
sense of concern and i come
and i think i said this before but i
come from a i grew up in california i'm
down the street from stanford right now
so i come from a very west coast central
very american-centric view and version
of privacy
and
you might have heard us talking about
some of the vaccine distribution and
sorry the shutdown of the county sort of
at the top of the call before before the
class officially started because i come
from the from that bias right the bias
that says it's better to be i want my
data to be more private i want it to be
able to control it and i want it i want
that i want to be safe so i want to shut
down the i want to be mathematically
safe and scientific and all that i think
though when you take a step back there
are different areas of the world so i
won't do the state to state thing and
keep it domestic but if you look at
different areas of the world there are
very different senses of privacy and i
think that looking at some of the
backgrounds of the people who are on the
call i think that you recognize that
there are very different sensibilities
and what i'll say is so i have a very
good somebody who's on my team in china
living in hong kong and what i'll tell
you is they have obviously a very
different sense of privacy right they
have required
vaccine but covered tracking contact
tracing on their phones built into their
apps required for them to be able to
navigate through society and so you
could say wow they they really have a
loss of privacy in comparison to the us
on the other hand and we are ewi so we
are 300 000 person global firm every
major country every major city we had
one office shut down in china through
the entire pandemic
in the u.s and europe all offices shut
down
all of our offices shut down so their
loss of privacy
came with the trade off of they were
able to keep their country going and
everyone knows the gdp stats and their
country is actually doing quite well
even through this pandemic
and i think that's i'm not arguing for
one or the other i i'm just arguing to
recognize
that there are trade-offs to be made
around this and the sensibilities of
different groups are just very different
while i take a very western view very
u.s centric view of our privacy and how
we should be how that should be looked
at i would say they look at it very
differently even individually my team
there looks at it very differently and
they're very happy that about the fact
that they can go and have dinner and
they never had to go outside in the
whole bit and they never had to shut
down i just wanted to there's different
sensibilities and i'd like to recognize
that those different sensibilities allow
for different outcomes there is a
follow-up question from lorenz who's in
the class in which kind of two ways of
posing the question which is one in a
world where a company's competitive
advantage is strongly influenced by its
access to and the use of personal data
how can governments and responsible
companies preserve privacy and user data
and in your view how can we prevent a
race to the bottom policy making that
forfeits privacy security and human
rights in the name of giving domestic
companies a competitive advantage i'll
take a first pass if no one else wants
to hop in
matt do you want to start or shall i
you first okay
i'm just going to inhabit as an answer
to that question stereotypical economist
because i don't think we actually need a
whole bunch of new concepts or tools to
to try to give an initial answer to that
question
what we need to think about is that
tech companies at the moment like any
line of business and industry sometimes
produce negative externalities
and in the absence of a level playing
field and a system of rules imposed by a
third party typically a government
those externalities will continue to be
produced rationally by companies if you
don't have to pay for the chemical
sludge that you push into the stream and
you can get away with it as a
competitive advantage to your more
environmentally sensible competitor you
have a financial incentive to continue
discharging the sludge
the same thing is true with say clear
vue ai and facial recognition right now
we might have a bunch of responsible
tech companies who say we are not going
to sell facial recognition technology to
police departments for the use on body
cameras but when clearview ai comes
along and there's a race to the bottom
because there's no set of rules that try
to limit a race to the bottom or to
internalize the externalities
you get predictable
rational behavior that leads to
sub-optimal negative outcomes so this is
just a standard issue economist's case
for where it is that a third-party
independent actor needs a step in order
to limit negative externalities and to
prevent a competitive dynamic in which
it's rational to race to the bottom
and i would jump onto that and say
pairing your answer with what jeff said
earlier how do we define those
externalities it's all about what we
not define them but how do we say that
they're negative right it's it's all
about what our principles are related to
privacy and security in our country and
as jeff same as jeff i'm also a
californian i also subscribe to the
californian
western sense of privacy and so forth
and i'm not here to be the big
government person who says oh we should
have access to everything and we should
be able to read your email in fact i'm
reading your email now
no i'm not but and so when we compare
ourselves to the these other countries
we have to decide internally as a
country
what's important to us right and when we
do that then the governments can step in
and create those rule sets and in fact
our system is designed such that
government is typically the slow actor
so we actually let the public debate
occur and for you know good or ill
government comes in later and decides
okay here's here are the rules that
we're going to live by and here's how
the policies we're going to follow
either through legislation or internal
government policies whatever happens to
be and it is not forward leaning and i
think that in many ways is one of the
protections that we have is that slow
bureaucracy which obviously has plenty
of negative negative side effects but we
don't have some random people in the
government leading the charge on what
those policies should be it's much more
reactive
i'm just laughing at matt's uh reading
my email now comment if he was reading
my email now he'd be so bored he'd
probably be falling asleep but just
but just that says hang on because i
think these are really fantastic
questions from again the class it's
really good and thoughtful i want to
recognize like what rob was saying about
inside an industry or a company's facial
recognition was his example you also
have to think about i think i would
argue the group should think about the
global nature of that competition
so there is a lot of advocacy in the us
for certain policies we see the eu with
this gdpr privacy policies from before
as a model but you can also recognize
that the difficulties of creating the
most advanced technologies
called ai driven technologies inside of
the eu with those data privacy policies
involved with somebody from the business
side who invests in building ai systems
and platforms for us and obviously we do
it as a firm for our our clients as well
you clearly can recognize the financial
differences of following those policies
we we obviously need to follow all
policies not just because we are
a global firm but because we are but the
nature of the work that we do requires
us to be very careful about following
regulatory policy everywhere and so for
us to follow the eu regulatory policy is
simply more expensive
than doing in the u.s and simply very
different from doing things in china and
as you think about the ecosystem while
it's nice to say hey in the us we're
going to decide to do x y or z because
that's feels good for us i just would
think that governments need to recognize
the broader implications it's not just
an ecosystem of the us companies it's
the facial recognition companies exist
in china the insurance company that
exists in china
the financial services company exists in
china nina that
will have better math
if you it would because they have lower
requirements on privacy therefore their
data is better therefore their
algorithms are better just
philosophically and so when you think
about what policies and ethics you want
to apply for your particular area of the
world you have to recognize that global
ecosystem that it may not be clear of
you it may be insert name of some
chinese company who's able to access
data in a better way
that is able to come in and say yeah no
we'll sell to your police force and so
the police force obviously needing to
find the best
answer for their needs buys from that
company is that an outcome that you want
it's it all works within this broader
system again not arguing that one's
better than the other we should make
decisions or not i just want to
recognize that when we make these
decisions it's not just in the isolation
of your industry or even your country
that's a great point jeff and i think
that is actually a responsibility of the
foreign policy establishment is to say
hey if we make these internal decisions
especially as we're a little more
inward focused these days these are the
repercussions that so we need to have
that debate but the only way you get
that knowledge and transmit it is to the
average citizen is through ambassadors
and and state department and so forth
rob so i would love for you to answer
this question that came from oleg in our
class given the differences between
china's approach versus that of the
united states regarding data privacy
what realistically is the us government
and corporate sector going to do about
that and similarly spencer also asks
more broadening it beyond china how do
you anticipate the us to respond to
other countries policies moving forward
yeah let me emphasize first that i'm no
foreign policy expert and i don't even
really even have public policy expertise
what i feel like i do have some
expertise in is democratic theory and
understanding of what makes democracy
distinctively
valuable
but having participated in a number of
these conversations and having taught
this class in which these geopolitical
issues arise for a couple of years at
least i say a few things but emphasize
the tentativeness here of them
so number one is i would love to see a
much greater r d budget produced not
merely by venture capitalists but
democratic governments to invest in
particular and frontier technologies in
ai
in order that we can try to produce
technological breakthroughs not merely
in the current paradigm of how it is
that in particular ai is working which
is a kind of centralized architecture in
which enormous data pools are
coupled with the
power of compute in order to produce
astonishing results i would love to see
frontier breakthroughs that produce
decentralized architectures
so that the same type of
decentralization that is inherent to the
benefit of a democratic government in
other words we don't have it as it were
an authoritarian architecture of ai
mapped onto a democratic architecture of
our political system that's part what in
my view benefits china hundreds of
millions of people abound a porous
boundary between the government and the
commercial industry and then an
unrivaled data pool that no other
industry or country has
if we can produce decentralized
architectures that itself would be a
beneficial development for democracy as
well as then for the innovators on the
frontier
that would be my first recipe as it were
and as i already put in the chat the the
goal would be to stop the frame or you
know break out of the frame of america
innovates europe regulates and there's
competition between democracies and
instead get democratic cooperation to
counter the geopolitical rise of digital
authoritarianism
thanks for sharing that rob i do want to
touch on the topic of ethical frameworks
both matt how you see it from your seat
within government and also rob some of
your efforts in terms of teaching ethics
as well uh question for matt first is in
terms of the dod recently launched a new
framework on ethical principles for ai
and the ic the intelligence community
also has its own principles of ai ethics
for the intelligence community
how do you think we should think about
developing and using ai to further
government's security objectives and
balancing that with some of these
ethical frameworks and principles
great question
so i think we so dod in my opinion is
and the government writ large is
actually way behind
in
all kinds of ways and a lot of it is
related to thought leadership when it
comes to ai ethics all the stuff that
rob just mentioned all the investments
that the us government should be
investing in those things and we we just
have chosen not to over the past decades
and in fact our only serious investment
in ai has occurred in the last
five years
putting real money money to it and so
when you look at the dod ai ethics
framework if if you read it i'll just
quickly tell you the the each one is a
single word so it's responsible
equitable traceable reliable and
governable
a lot of those actually are a little
more focused on basically what we call
about protecting this person so using ai
internal to
to provide services to our citizens but
in in fact we should probably want uh to
think about how do we use ai against
people that we don't like so much and do
we really want them to be responsible do
we really want ai to be equitable when
it comes to
challenging an adversary and so i say
that because a lot of the discussion
even on this call has focused on how do
we apply
ai ethically to
to our citizens but that's not really
what the department of defense does it
does you know it does some of it so my
my i think my thoughts on that is we
actually need to
employ concepts like we do intelligence
collection where we actually
specifically have two sets of rules we
have sets of rules that we use involving
u.s persons and that's u.s citizens
corporations or people that we even
suspect to be have connections to the
united states and people that are not us
first or groups that are not u.s persons
but it comes down at the end of the day
it comes down to really sitting down and
thinking through those rule sets which
frankly you know as i i opened with i
think we're really behind on when it
comes to
when it comes to thought leadership in
in these areas and i'd like to see more
investment in both the thinking and the
r d side of things in the very you know
near future
and rob question for you just in terms
of teaching ethics can we teach ethics
and how can and should we train the next
generation of students and computer
scientists on ethical uses of ai
great yeah totally natural and important
question and i'm going to give a really
short hand answer that each of which
could each of the little components
could be longer
i think there are three different levels
or sort of places points of intervention
for thinking ethically in order to
produce more ethical technology or more
ethical people
the three points or the three level
levels are number one
personal ethics make sure that everyone
has a moral compass by the time they
graduate you know with a ba or a bs
degree or some other professional degree
i think this is the least interesting
aspect of ethics and that if as a
society we have to rely on people being
moral saints we are totally and
hopelessly lost i think to myself does
does business ethics prevent the rise of
corrupt or venal business people no if
we insist upon a personal moral compass
as the only stop gap against bad
behavior we're still going to get
elizabeth holmes of the world we're
still going to get lance armstrong's of
the world bad behavior happens
everywhere if you read what everything i
learned and everything i needed to learn
i learned in kindergarten you've already
gotten the basic lessons that you
shouldn't lie cheat or steal good enough
we don't need personal ethics in higher
education
level two
professional ethics you should find a
way to have professional norms where
groups of professionals self-govern or
self-police their own behavior
computer scientists are way behind the
times here or i should say they're i
think of the computer science or ai
science as a in the unruly teenager
phase of life they have discovered all
of their powers but behave totally
irresponsibly because they haven't yet
matured in order to mature into a
professional discipline compare it to
biomedical ethics where you have all
kinds of institutional rules not laws
but institutional norms of the
profession that help to govern some of
the work of biomedical research and
biomedical discovery experimentation
finally the third and the most important
level of ethics is social and political
ethics that's what we've been talking
about how to think about the frameworks
in a democratic society that help
illuminate how to balance values how to
how to strike trade-offs in a way that
benefits all people how to arrange the
relative balance of power between
industry non-profit society and
government these are domains in which
there's no singularly correct answer
we're not going to optimize for any one
particular thing
and we're going to find a way in which
to have hard conversations with each
other that extract decision making from
any one person or any one place so that
we can um all try to contribute to a
broader conversation about what's what
matters to us socially those are the
most important and interesting ethical
questions and that's why i think a place
like hai is so important it says hai's
value proposition to the world is
stop putting the ai scientists by
themselves into the lab to produce
breakthrough technologies and then let
the social scientists and politicians
come along after ai has been released
into the wild put everyone in the lab
together to balance those value
trade-offs as we develop these new
frontier technologies should we have a.i
that automates human beings out of jobs
or that augments human beings in what
they do in life that's a set of
conversations that you have in the lab
not afterwards
you get the spirit of the idea here the
interesting ethical questions are not
about personal ethics i don't care
whether or not you are a moral saint or
not we should have institutional
arrangements that allow for individual
bad behavior and contain it and then the
question is how to balance value
trade-offs in which we all have an
interest and a stake we don't want the
policy makers alone we don't want
philanthropic leaders alone we don't
want industry leaders alone making those
choices or decisions we want everyone
with a voice in that conversation
hence democracy
i would be remiss if we didn't talk
about the role of industry versus
government and rob you alluded to the
need for all these stakeholders together
in the room there's always been a
tension between the private sector and
government jeff what role do you think
the private sector should have in
developing these sorts of ethical
standards for ai and how do we
also ensure matt especially for you that
we have these standards in place and
what is the role that government should
have and being able to intervene
specifically before it's too late yeah i
think rob made a great point about h.a.i
which is all parties really need to come
together on this one
and in particular on ai or frontier tech
the frontier technology of the moment
and
it's really tangible so you're out in
the world and you're trying to build
stuff it becomes very
the need for all parties to come to the
table becomes very tangible
right so it's i know we're talking about
ethics and policy and a bit in theory
here but in practice when you're trying
to build something and deploy it
all these voices have to come together
so we we have very deep relationships
with governments because of the
regulatory nature of all the audit and
assurance practice tax practice that we
have
so we are in constant communication with
them around different policy and what
you do see is what matt alluded to
i think that there are great people in
governments around the world who are
minds and hearts in the right place
but frankly right now they are
completely overwhelmed
with all the different things that are
the pandemic being the primary but all
the different aspects of the world that
they need to take care of and this is
yet another
aspect of the world an incredibly
important one you have people who
recognize that but they are overwhelmed
so they can't do it alone they gotta
they have to come to the table uh
clearly academia needs to come to the
table because the frameworks and how the
sort of the leading edge thinking comes
from there but companies have a
particularly important place i think
right now and i'm actually going to go
outside of ai and frontier technologies
but if you look at the corporate role
currently in the esg conversation right
the the social good conversation esg the
brt sorry the business roundtable ey
our chairman ceo is one of the
signatories of that original signatories
of that we do a lot of that thinking
with the wef we're trying to put in the
metrics into our own organization and
there's a series of signatories to that
document ceos basically of the jpmorgans
the bfas of the world who signed on to
that document who are trying to make
this huge effort to put these metrics
into their organizations again to
raleigh's point not because they're
regulated to but because they feel it's
the right thing to do as an organization
fits with the purpose of the
organization and that is a tangible way
that
the government not just governments not
just academia but the companies
themselves have to take on that
responsibility as well
yes we need to bring together all these
three voices one thing that i think has
been hard for this particular issue is
that there are so many different groups
who are talking about this that we
haven't actually brought together one
single global group to be able to talk
together there's just lots of different
fragmentation of of teams and group
china trying to figure this out
and matt i would love your perspectives
on this and also just tack on a comment
that zach from the class made in terms
of the dod traditionally generating r d
that has been the leading edge of many
important innovations whether it's
internet gps and perhaps in my opinion
this hasn't been the case for ai and
given that what are some of the
implications how do we think about
government's role when tech development
outruns policy what is the role of
policy and how does it keep up
yeah sure so you're absolutely right
when it comes to r d dod and the
government has traditionally over the
last 50 60 70 years been the leader
developing all kinds of technologies but
ai we are woefully behind but i'm not i
said woefully because i in my opinion we
are too far behind but overall to
actually combine robs and jeff's idea i
want government to be a
equal partner at the table when it comes
to developing these frameworks and
frankly a partner to
to explain the government's perspective
right military operations have different
needs so we need to look at them in a
different light when it comes to ethical
frameworks
but at the end of the day i also want
the government to be a slow implementer
we need the academics and we need the
industry to really be pushing ahead and
working all these things but we don't
want government to actually come in and
codify pieces of those ethics that we
decide are correct in legislation a
because
then that's permanent right no not
exactly but it is much more permanent
than other things and that's the
ultimate codification of an ethical
standard because when we pass the law
forward so in that sense i i want the
government to be an equal part in their
discussion but as an implementer to be
the slow uh person now it's happening
naturally that way
to directly to jeff's point is weird we
right now dod when it comes to ai
there's a three-star general out there
who would probably shoot me if you heard
me say this but we're just a bunch of
pilot projects right when it comes to
artificial intelligence in in the
department of defense it's just the
navy's got like 850 ai and they're
essentially pilot projects we haven't
really deployed these things in any
major weapon systems we're not really
pushing things out there and so there's
this huge gap in the people in dod who
can be an equal partner in the
conversation to jeff's point so that's
the gap we need to close so we can be
that equal partner share our
perspectives but then government as an
implementer i do intentionally want to
be slow as things come turn into
legislation and i want to spend the last
few minutes just covering a few other
questions that popped up from the class
this one's from andrew feel free to jump
in uh to provide additional commentary
on this one as well so the question is
there
do you think there is a need for a
global agreement on ethical ai can you
imagine scenarios where a lack of
agreement globally on the ethical use of
ai can affect other countries
my initial
thought is
i would i think the power in that
is only is realized
when it ai decision making is coupled
with things that we don't want on a
global scale nuclear weapons for example
but i think a lot of our previous
discussion is it's hard to have the some
of those ethical standards because our
deferences of what our principles are
across the world is so hard but there
are a few areas nuclear weapons chemical
weapons biological weapons where we
would want to push towards can i add to
that ernestine
i i think the question also
and matt's response helps illuminate
something important that gets back to
the previous question about the
relationship between industry and
government and commercial commercially
led breakthroughs in technology and then
the slower
often more inefficient regulatory
responses of government and the reason i
try to connect the two here is
i often think it's a productive tension
when we have
optimizers or seekers of new
efficiencies located within industry
but when you apply that orientation to
democratic government you've made an
important misunderstanding
democratic governments are not purpose
built for optimizing any particular
thing their purpose built for avoiding
some worst case scenarios and allowing
for a contest of interest to be sought
to be
resolved or you know refereed slowly
over time
in the best of circumstances then to get
to the particular question what could a
global agreement on ethics and ai
potentially produce
i'm with matin saying the best we could
hope for is that there are certain
things we try to avoid that are really
bad outcomes i would put on the list for
example
automated weapons where humans are no
longer in the loop i would like to see a
global agreement that the development of
frontier military technologies that
involve automated tools
always should require a human decision
maker to authorize lethal use cases
those would be beneficial global
agreements to have in the same way again
as matt said that we sought for various
nuclear cases or nuclear uses
we shouldn't strive to optimize for our
best outcomes across the world if we
heed the lesson of democracy that's not
what democratic arrangements are good
for there's a productive tension between
industry and democratic government
that's best when they're doing different
things
andrew does that answer your question
are there additional comments you'd like
to make on that topic
no i'm pretty satisfied with that i
wasn't i think it offered a lot of
clarity into what
how that should look on a global scale
so i appreciate that thank you actually
if i could honestly just just and i
guess the group's knowledge like there's
there's a whole series of groups going
trying to do this so i'm going to be
this is literally i was being briefed by
our public policy our vice chair bob
paul's yesterday there's the
icgai the gpai a subcommittee of the
oecd plus a couple countries unesco's
united nations ai group council of
europe and i think that so the i agree
with the comments that were made before
there's a lot of different groups
working on this that the fear i have is
that there's so many groups working on
it because it's so hard and because
there's so many different varied
interests that we don't come to the
avoidance of these truly
catastrophic use cases that matt and rob
illuminated which are you're very
catastrophic in my mind and i think that
so i would like to see to your question
i would love to see some coming together
around that i don't know if it's
possible
but i would love to to see and i know
there are groups that are trying to
bring together that conversation but as
you can imagine the the conversation
gets delayed uh because there's so many
interests at heart to try to bring that
even the conversation together
but to your point jeff i think to
highlight the challenge of that is there
is no worldwide nuclear control regime
right so there we there are nuclear
weapons pointed at us or at least near
us right now that we have no treaty
signatories to those countries that's up
to your point a serious challenge so i
want to wrap up today's discussion with
one uh final question from lorenz feel
free to jump in with additional
commentary on this so the question is in
the future
with more of our world being online and
digital assumption that more and more
data is likely being collected in your
view what a personal digital identity
look like in 2030
and and i'm just going to jump in
quickly thank you
yeah it's a slightly amorphous question
i guess i thought about this recently
you know what will will we
have some sort of an analogous
personality or a persona in the web that
sort of controls our whole
how we appear in the world
rather than having all this disparate
data appear in a gazillion places and
i have a really hard time putting that
into words but i hope you guys
understand roughly what i'm trying to
get at
i'm i'm pretty sure it's going to
involve cat memes so
somewhere between now and then that's
going to be my avatar but i i think the
actual disparate nature of everything is
actually one of the huge things that
protects our privacy so i i've i have a
security clearance
opm was reached i don't know 10 years
ago that's where we keep all our
security information our security
investigation information it was hacked
almost certainly by country in asia but
they didn't get everything right now
hackers have gotten other things in
other places at other times so in some
ways we want a decentralized approach
and i don't i i and the other piece of
it is i do know that we're moving
towards biometric identification both
physical biometric and then and the
habit the how fast you type in a on a
computer to constantly identify you this
so that you have access to that that
those sets of information
i don't know if that is at all what is
what you are asking about but those are
the two thoughts that come to mind
yeah i'll tag on matt i actually think
that there's probably a lot of our
digital identity that exists with and i
have to speak groundly because they're
all of our clients and so we don't name
our clients by name but large search
companies large social companies that
have a very meaningful profile of all of
us given our usage of their services but
also our
our our ability to log in using those
centered the the search login across a
number of different sites so the
aggregation of who you are lorenzo is
probably
there even though it is somewhat
decentralized thank goodness but i think
they're getting a pretty darn good
profile and i think that you could
probably if you wanted to spend more
time on this look at china's efforts
with the human scoring right
they are
centralizing these efforts and what
would it what it could it look like in a
centralized way i think they're they're
showing us what it might look like so if
you looked over there i think you'd
probably have a reasonable idea of where
it's headed for 2030 and what it could
look like for the rest of the world
there for for 2030.
rob would love to give you the last word
just not only on this question but just
more broadly on this class topic
in any final concluding thought yeah
maybe what i'm about to say is totally
predictable but since it hasn't come up
i'll at least
lob it into conversation here lorenz
what your question makes me think about
in terms of our identity calls attention
to
genetic editing and the the crispr
revolution when i think of if i had to
identify what are the two most important
things to pay attention to for the
remainder of the 21st century it's the
frontier of ai and the frontier of gene
editing both of which
threaten to unseat our very
understanding of what it means to be
human
a kind of race between silicon and
carbon and our identities our sense of
ourselves is what's at stake and so
these are the two most important topics
to get everyone
paying attention to and working on at
the same time
and eventually the two will come
together of course it isn't just
separate revolutions but they'll be
conjoined